all right so you see things have become
more positive but again it we had to
start with the darkness to fuel our
moving into the light right whereas once
we were blind now we can see look at
what has opened up for us so now we're
got flow now you've seen why this has
changed my life and I need it on a
regular basis
okay you got flow but then what do you
do right so then you have to find your
passion that's the bumper sticker find
your passion follow your dreams figure
out how you can make a contribution with
your passion but I get it
not everybody can immediately know what
they're passionate about there's so many
options there's an infinite boundless
menu of possibilities Timothy Leary
talks about the vertigo of freedom
there's so much to do I don't know
parallel you're paralyzed I get it
it's overwhelming the paralysis of
choice open up Netflix how many times
have you spent browsing for 20 minutes
and then it's like I want to watch
anything no matter what you choose is
not gonna be the right thing it's up so
uh you have to figure out this this
passion thing from all the possible ways
in which you could invest yourself
Steven Kotler also from the flow Genome
Project wrote this article in Forbes
that I was like holy he
deconstructed passion here is the
formula and I'm not into like worksheets
and workshops to teach you how to do
this stuff but this was so clear then I
was like oh got to make a video
about it here's how you find your
passion if you don't know it you make a
list of 15 things that you're really
curious about right Elizabeth Gilbert
who wrote Eat Pray Love often talks
about the pressure of knowing your
passion and she says if you don't know
your passion at least chase curiosity
because at least you know things you're
curious about them you can make a list
so Cutler goes on make a list of 15
things are curious about so let's say
I'm curious about space I'm curious
about existentialism I'm curious about
the singularity like you make a list and
then you have 15 things now what you're
gonna do is you're gonna try to sort of
create a Venn diagram and you're gonna
find out where these things overlap
we're to three to five of those 15
things you're curious about overlap
right because now they're spilling into
each other see anything you're curious
about is squirting dopamine so it's
already there's neurobiology there right
but if you have multiple things that
you're curious about overlapping that's
a lot of neurobiology all right follow
the chemical trail you know like we are
mediated by neuro chemistry our
ecstasy's and our sadness is all
mediated by neuro chemistry so just
chase that dopamine hit but be smart
about it you know not the slot-machine
style dopamine hit but like here's a lot
of things I'm curious about here's where
they overlap that is the way to your
passion clear easy follow along and you
get it then he says now you know your
passion or at least the direction of it
find a need in the world that can be
served by your passion right because
then it's like you have curiosity which
leads to passion the passion that leads
to purpose oh yeah
a reason to get up in the morning as on
debt a reason for being a reason for
moving a reason for taking action a
reason that matters a reason that makes
you matter curiosity passion purpose and
guess what you know what your flow is so
you can also bring insights from that
idea right so these are the things that
give me flow these are the things I'm
curious about these are were these
things I'm curious about overlap and
they overlap in ways that if I go this
direction I can also be in flow when
those curiosities overlap
holy-shit and there's the purpose that I
can serve by being in flow playing with
all the things I'm curious about and
serving a need in the world oh my god
you figured it out that's it
done go home bye like that's the
solution I try to apply that to my own
life I ask myself you know on darker
days you know if I have a cold and I'm
having
then she'll meltdown because my body's
not performing that they I'm like okay
well okay I get to do videos about
things that I really love and I'm
passionate about all these things I want
to talk about them in my videos and
making the video that's great people
seem to like the videos okay so that's
good I have a have a purpose you know
and then finally right this this love
for technology that I was talking about
again a metaphor for all the ways in
which we redefine our boundaries in the
world right so the guys behind the
XPrize foundation recently came up with
this idea in terms of like you know
purpose they're like in the age of
exponential technologies and the age in
which technology is going so fast and
the age in which a young person in rural
Africa with a smartphone has better
communications technology than a head of
state had 25 years ago the
supercomputers to change the world and I
want everybody's hands in the age of
that which is the age we live in today
how can you come up with an idea your
curiosity your passion your purpose and
idea that gets you in the flow that can
actually positively touch a billion
people and they said let's reframe the
term billionaire and say that a new
billionaire in the age of exponential
technologies and existential angst the
new billionaire is somebody who figures
out what they're curious about what
they're passionate about what puts them
in the zone and what they can conceive
to serve the world with that will
positively touch a billion people now
that is an ambition worth having I hope
so now I'm going to show you the next
video which is sums up this notion of
finding your passion because I really
want it to hit home please show it so
there was a wonderful article by Steven
Kotler published in Forbes about how to
find your passion it's a question we ask
ourselves every single day we've all
been told that a life of passion is a
life that means something but how do we
identify our passions it's not always
easy so one of the things that Steven
Kotler breaks down is that he says that
passion essentially exists in the
intersection between multiple things
that you're curious about so he says the
first thing you should do if you want to
identify your passion is to make a list
of all the things that you're curious
about all the things that you wonder
about be as specific as you can and then
create kind of a Venn diagram and try to
figure out where the thing is that
you're curious about three or more
intersect and that's the sweet spot
that's where there is energy that's
where there is dopamine and neurobiology
multiple streams of curiosity intersect
at a space called passion right and then
once you've identified your passion then
you can figure out how to turn that
passion into a purpose turn that passion
into a purpose make a list of 15 things
in the world 15 challenges you'd like to
see solved and then figure out which one
of those challenges can be served by
your passion so then you see curiosity
leads to passion multiple streams of
curiosity leads to passion identifying
problems in the world that can be served
by your passion leads to purpose and
then my friends you've impregnated your
life with a sense of significance with a
sense of meaning and then you can go
forth my brothers who can go forward
[Applause]
[Music]
I thought it was a great article take
note Steven Cutler's work flow Genome
Project how to find your passion